le corps inanimé de ma femme avec mon
mon fils le bras a bloqué en dessous je
sors le bras de mon fils de sous ma
femme et
je commence très rapidement les massages
cardiaques le bouche-à-bouche paniqué à
la nappe les pompiers et les parents de
Maëva au palais de justice de Pontoise
lundi dernier
Christian Rousseau et sa femme Graziella
s'apprête à vivre une semaine difficile
dans quelques minutes va débuter le
procès de l'assassin présumé de leur
fille Maëva la jeune femme a été
sauvagement tuée sous les yeux de son
bébé
voilà Maëva et Lorenzo il faut bien que
le criminel il voit ça voir s'il peut
éprouver un peu de
[Musique]
regrets un minimum
pour la première fois depuis trois ans
les parents de Maëva vont devoir faire
face à celui qui aurait pris la vie de
leur fille et briser la leur
[Musique]
ils appréhendent d'autant plus ce moment
que celui qui sera dans le box des
accusés est un ancien ami à eux
la cour d'assise à 5 jours pour répondre
aux questions qui hante Christian et
Graziella
[Musique]
pourquoi leur fille a-t-elle été tuée le
meurtrier présumé avait-il prémédité son
geste
Maeva Rousseau grandit dans un village
en région parisienne elle passe une
enfance heureuse avec ses parents et ses
quatre grands frères
à l'adolescence elle sort avec Rodolphe
un jeune du coin ici tout le monde se
connaît le père de Maëva et le père de
Rodolphe Alain beruet sont très amis sur
cette photo on les voit tous les deux
côte à côte
[Musique]
mais l'amour est entre les deux
adolescents ne durent pas
Maëva rêve d'une vie toute tracée elle
travaille dans un salon de coiffure et
veut fonder une famille
[Musique]
Michel sa collègue est très proche
d'elle
dans cette carte vagin parce qu'en fait
c'est le début de notre amitié avec
Maeva à toi la meilleure collègue que
j'ai pu avoir on s'est rencontré dans
mon cœur Maëva qui t'aime
Michel se souvient que Maëva n'avait
qu'une idée en tête trouver l'homme de
sa vie
c'est une jeune femme naïve qui rêvait
du grand amour nous étions toutes mariés
au salon de coiffure donc Saint-Amand
qui avait prendre modèle sur nous si
c'est une fille qui n'avait pas moi j'ai
rencontré à l'âge de 19 ans elle avait
déjà c'était déjà une femme c'était déjà
une femme
à l'âge de 20 ans Maëva entame une
relation avec Alan un autre jeune du
village très vite le couple décide
d'emménager ensemble
il s'installe dans cette petite maison
assurance dans le Val-d'Oise
2 ans après le début de leur relation en
2011 Maeva accouche de Lorenzo
maman comblée la jeune femme à la vie
dont elle avait toujours rêvé
[Musique]
son compagnon Allan se souvient de cette
période heureuse
c'était ma femme ma princesse
c'est quelqu'un de demande loyal de
fidèle et on avait beaucoup beaucoup de
projets ensemble et on avait toute la
vie devant nous
bravo mon chéri
[Musique]
pourtant l'ancien petit copain de Maëva
Rodolphe va venir troubler cette jolie
vie de famille
même s'il a une nouvelle compagne le
jeune homme n'arrive toujours pas à
oublier Maëva il essaie de la
reconquérir et ne cesse de lui envoyer
des messages
ce qui énerve beaucoup à l'âne
j'ai senti qu'il y avait une rivalité
j'avais vu Rodolphe
voilà il était pas content du tout que
je sois avec Maeva le dernier message
qu'il a envoyé c'était j'ai envie de toi
donc c'est plus qui est explicite je lui
dis si tu continues je vais je vais
aller voir ta copine et je vais aller
lui montrer les SMS
un soir Alan mais ses menaces à
exécution il va voir la compagne de
Rodolphe et lui montre les fameux SMS
celles-ci se sent trahie et qui te
Rodolphe
Rodolphe et fou de rage contre Alan
après avoir bu de l'alcool il prend sa
voiture et décide d'aller s'expliquer
avec lui mais sur la route il rate un
virage et perd le contrôle de son
véhicule
l'accident est fatal
Rodolphe est retrouvée mort à quelques
mètres de sa voiture dans un champ
Alain beruet le père de Rodolphe est
effondré par la mort de son fils il
considère que les responsables de ce
drame sont à l'âne et Maëva
[Musique]
avec sa femme il en vient même à
proférer des menaces contre le jeune
couple comme ce jour ou en sortant du
cimetière d'après Alan il s'en serait
pris violemment à Maeva c'est Maeva qui
visait fonce vraiment sur elle à la
plaque contre la voiture et ensuite plus
d'un sud des menaces de mort tu vas
souffrir comme comme moi j'ai souffert
son mari est arrivé
une minute peut-être après et lui il
nous a aussi lancé des plus insultes
j'ai tout de suite mis Maëva qui qui
tremblait qui faisait de l'asthme qui
arrivait plus à respirer qui était
terrorisé et moi aussi dans la voiture
le jeune couple va immédiatement porter
plainte
malgré cela le père de Maeva reste très
ami avec Alain beruet le père de
Rodolphe il tente même d'apaiser les
tensions
moi je voulais absolument
arranger les choses je me suis dit fut
la perte de leur fils je pense que
l'ont perdu la tête quelque part
c'est pour ça que j'étais à la rencontre
pour arranger le coup voilà quoi
le conflit semble être résolu
[Musique]
mais le 8 avril 2012 vers 3h du matin
après son travail Alan rentre chez lui
et découvre une scène d'horreur
j'entends mon fils sur les un cri que
j'avais jamais entendu hurlement du
monde enfant j'avais jamais entendu je
monte en haut et je découvre le corps
inanimé de ma femme avec mon mon fils le
bras bloqué en dessous je sors le bras
de mon fils de sous la femme et
je commencerai rapidement les massages
cardiaque le bouche-à-bouche paniquer
Alan appelle les pompiers et les parents
de Maeva quand nous sommes arrivés là où
ils étaient en train de d'essayer de
réanimation
c'est au bout d'un moment qu'on a
attendu le médecin est venu me voir en
me demandant si elle avait des allergies
j'ai dit non et
il est remonté et puis descendu en me
disant c'est fini
la jeune femme est morte à la suite de
plusieurs coups très violents notamment
sur le crâne
allan a aussitôt de forts soupçons sur
l'auteur du crime pour lui c'est le père
de Rodolphe il en informe aussitôt les
gendarmes
je sais qui c'est c'est Alain
pourtant à lumberuet a un comportement
tout à fait normal notamment envers son
ami le père de Maëva
le lendemain ou sur le lendemain
on s'est croisé dans le village et
comment dire la présenter ses
condoléances
on peut à la suite on va
continuer de me côtoyer en fait mais
curieusement l'homme semble s'intéresser
de prêt à l'enquête
c'est lorsque ils ont retrouvé une paire
de gants il y a une enquête dans le
secteur
il va poser la question mais cette
fameuse question là pourra poser que
moi-même il a posé à autre chose au
courant est-ce que leur trou de l'ADN
dans une perte de gants
mais moi sur le coup je me dis mais
c'est une amie qui s'intéresse
à l'enquête
rapidement l'enquête de voisinage
apporte des témoignages déterminants
le soir du meurtre des voisins auraient
aperçu Alain beruet avec des gants de
ménage roses aux mains devant la maison
de Maëva
[Musique]
l'homme est alors interpellé et placé en
garde à vue
très vite à lumbervé à vous avoir tué
Maëva sur un coup de folie
le soir du meurtre il aurait dîné chez
des amis avec son plus jeune fils
pour la première fois celui-ci accepte
de témoigner il raconte que ce soir-là
son père était très alcoolisé
le repas il est encore bu il commence à
pleurer après il a fait des propos parce
qu'il était alcoolisé il disait il
disait je suis vraiment triste sans mon
fils et tout
[Musique]
il est complètement ivre il s’équipe de
bottes en caoutchouc de gants de
vaisselle et seront sur la tombe de son
fils Rodolphe pour la nettoyer dit-il
[Applaudissements]
selon son avocat Maître Louis Inna à ce
moment-là aucun plan précis en tête il
va sur la tombe de son fils il va sur
les lieux de l'accident ou celui-ci est
décédé et suivant son chemin il finit
par arriver à Cherence ne sachant s'il
va trouver Maëva ou Alan ou Maëva et
Alan il veut avoir des explications en
ce qui concerne le décès de son fils
avant d'entrer dans la maison à
lumberhuet prends soin de récupérer une
batte de baseball dans sa camionnette au
cas où dit-il le couple serait armé
pendant la reconstitution il explique
aux gendarmes être rentré sans
effraction la porte n'étant pas fermée à
clé
Allan n'est pas là Maëva est avec son
bébé à l'étage
il affirme avoir discuté avec elle
pendant 5 minutes
[Musique]
la conversation aurait dégénéré et il
l'aurait frappé à plusieurs reprises
avec sa batte de base-ball
pour son avocat son acte n'était pas
prémédité vous croyez qu'il est pris
dans un projet criminel comme
l'accusation pourrait me retourner la
proposition mais pas du tout il est
complètement désemparé cet homme et il
est pas désemparé aujourd'hui c'était
hier c'était avant-hier c'est monté
doucement brute et puis ça finit par
exploser
au mois d'avril 2012 mais pour les
avocats des parties civils aucun doute
il y a bien préméditation tout d'abord
le fait de prendre des gants en
caoutchouc et des bottes pour éviter
tout ADN il peut dire que il est arrivé
par hasard il peut dire que la porte
s'est ouvrait toute seule il peut dire
que tout s'est fait tout seul il
n'empêche qu'il arrive accoutré sa femme
dira il est déguisée il a mis il a tous
les éléments sur lui pour accomplir son
dessin pré méditation ou non devant la
cour d'assises alain berlé a exprimé des
regrets et demander pardon à la famille
de Maëva
des regrets formulés par écrit dans une
lettre que nous nous sommes procurés
[Musique]
chaque matin je suis réveillé par le
regret ma seule envie c'est de revenir
en arrière
Maëva pardonne-moi et que ta famille me
pardonne repose en paix
[Musique]
vendredi à l'issue des cinq jours de
procès la Cour a reconnu qu'il
s'agissait bien d'un crime prémédité à
lumberway a été condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour l'assassinat
de Maëva Rousseau
une peine insuffisante pour la mère de
Maëva
on le ver duc pas juste
chez toi
ce qui mériterait qu'on lui en prison
voilà c'est tout ce que je viens
y faire mais madame Rousseau aucune
peine n'aurait ramené votre fille aucune
peine aucune Alain berwet à 10 jours
pour faire appel de cette décision
quel que soit sa peine la mort de Maëva
aura brisé la vie de toute une famille
[Musique]